อาซึ
สะหวัดดีค่ะครูเองสวัสดีค่ะครูต้องสวัสดี
ค่ะเรียนเต้นกันใช่ไหม
กูเองสบายดีไหมคะอ่าสบายดีค่ะร่างกายสบาย
ดีเสียงแหบเล็กน้อยนะคะ
แต่งแหบเล็กน้อยวิ๋ลืมเสียบใหม่นะเนี่ย
กูเองนี่มั้ยด้วยหรอซื้อใหม่มากูต้อง
หวังเร็วลองดูว่าเสียงจะเปลี่ยนไหมนะคะ
ลองดูค่ะลองดูลองดูกูต้องได้ยินไม่ได้ยิน
บอกกูอีกด้วยนะคะ
เป็นปลั้กนะคะแล้วก็จะเสียง
น้องดูนะคะเสียบไม้อุ้ยเข้าไหมอ่ะเสียบ
แล้ว
ไม่ได้ยินจริงเปล่าอ๋องั้นกูไอ้ก็ต้อง We
Are
กูต้องได้ยินหรือยังคะโอเคได้ยินนะค่ะ
อ้าวแล้วจะไปคุยอีกไม่ได้ยินเสียงกูต้อง
อ้าวเออ
ทำไมคุยไม่ได้ยินเสียงกูต้องทำไมอ่ะอีกกู
ต้องได้ยินเสียงตัวเองไหมได้ยินค่ะแล้วก็
เอกก็ได้ยินเสียงต้อมโอเคได้ดีแล้วนะ
โอเคแล้วนะคือครูเอ๋แน่ผึ้งผึ้งผึ้ง
เคยใช้ไมโครโฟน
[เพลง]
ไมโครโฟนนะคะปกติเนี่ยพูดคือต้องเสียงดัง
ๆเองเลยห้องใหญ่ๆตอนนี้ก็
เจ็บคอนิดหน่อยก็เลยใช้ไมโครโฟน
[เพลง]
โอเคค่ะเป็นดังนั้นได้ยินเสียงดังชัดที่
เนี่ยได้ยินค่ะแต่เหมือนเสียงครูเอ๋อ่ะ
พูดออกมาอยากได้ยินเสียงกูเองมันมาจาก
คอมพิวเตอร์อ๋อ
โอเคตอนนี้ดังชัดไหมคะว่าเอ๋ลองหยิบ
ไมโครโฟนมาพูดที่ใกล้ใกล้ๆนะฮะสวัสดีค่ะ
อ๋อ ok  ok เข้าค่ะเข้านะอ๋ออ๋อกูเอามา
อีกไว้ไกลๆใช่ไหมคะใช่ค่ะตอนนี้ก็ก็ใหม่
ใกล้ๆแล้วต้องถามคุณต้องพระคุณต้องจะรู้
วิธีการพูดต้องก็มีนึงอ้ะหาครูต้อมไม่ได้
ใช้
คอมพิวเตอร์ครูต้อมเสียงดีฟังชัดค่ะคะ
อาภาๆโอเคคุยเอกก็ได้ยินเสียงกูต้องครู
ต้อมก็ได้ยินเสียงครูเอ๋เดี๋ยวเราจะรู้
ว่านักเรียนจะได้ยินเสียงเราไหม
สรุปเราได้ยินนักเรียน
น่ะสิ
คอมพิวเตอร์ Records ไม่ได้ OK ถ้าหากคุณ
ต้องวันนี้ครูเอ๋มีคำถามก่อนที่จะคุยกัน
พูดต้อมคุณต้อมชอบเลี้ยงสัตว์มั้ย
ชอบค่ะชอบโอเคคุณต้องมีสัตว์เลี้ยงที่
บ้านไหมคะอย่างเช่นหมาแมวปลา
ปลาไม่ใช่ปลานะปลา
ปลานกมีไหมคะเมื่อก่อนตอนกูต้มเด็กๆมีค่ะ
มีอะไรคะอย่าบอกว่ามีงูนะคะ
มีหมาแมวปลานกระต่ายนกกระต่ายด้วยนะต่าย
ก็มีประกาศให้ฉันอย่างนี้เลยแค่นิ่ง
อย่างนี้มั้งอะไรอย่างนี้ก็ได้จำหน่ายใน
ฟันๆแล้วก็มีเปล่าตัวเล็กๆ
อ้าวญี่ปุ่นป่ะใช่ค่ะมีหูสุดต้องเรียน
เยอะเลยนะเนี้ยไงแมว
ปลา
หมา
กระต่ายร้องยังไงไม่ร้องกระต่ายไม่ร้อง
จ่ายไม่พูดนะคะอ่ะเต่าเต่าร้องไม่ร้อง
ปลาล่ะคะค่ะก็ไม่ร้องพูด
ใต้ใช่กาอาชอบ
อารมณ์ค่ะใช่อ๋อเมื่อก่อนกูต้องเลี้ยงตอน
นี้ไม่เลี้ยงแล้วหรอคะตอนนี้คุณต้องอยู่
คอนโดค่ะ
งงเขาไม่ให้เลี้ยงหมอเสียดายน้อง
ครูเอกก็ชอบเลี้ยงหมาตามเด็กๆนะคะ whoami
หมาแต่แม่และครูเองก็ดูคอนโดเหมือนครู
ต้อม
อยู่กรุงเทพฯอยู่คอนโดอยู่ต่างจังหวัด
อยู่บ้านที่บ้านครูเอ๋นะมีหมา
มากกว่า 10 ตัวหัวมีแมวตอนนี้โชคดีแมวตาย
ไปมั่งแมวก็เยอะๆเมื่อก่อนมีแมวสิบกว่า
ตัว
มากคือทั้งหมาทั้งแมวกูเอกเคยนับนะ 1  2
3  4 มากที่สุดที่เคยมีคือ 30 ตัว
เยอะจน
ไม่ใช่ของกูเองของคุณแม่เดี๋ยวของพี่
เลี้ยงเยอะๆก็เหนื่อยนะพูดเอ๋เหนื่อยล่ะ
คะแต่ครูเอ๋ก็ไม่ได้เลี้ยงแล้วตอนนี้
ไม่ได้เลี้ยงสัตว์เลี้ยงนะคะแต่เลี้ยง
สัตว์นี้
ยังไม่มีสัตว์เลี้ยงแต่เลี้ยงสัตว์ยังไง
งงน้องน้องสิไม่เข้าใจกูต้องงงภาษาไทยนะ
คะ kuai พูดเองต้ององค์เองค่ะงงคือ
อะไรไม่เข้าใจงงนะครูเองบอกว่าครูเอ๋ไม่
มีสัตว์เลี้ยงที่กรุงเทพฯไม่มีแต่ครูเอ๋
เลี้ยงสหัสขอ
ดูเห็นเลี้ยงยังไงคะเดี๋ยวค่อยให้ดูค่ะ
คุณต้อง Love ที่ที่ที่ที่ที่บ้านครูเอ๋
นี่คอนโดใช่ไหม
คุณต้องเห็นหน้านี้นะว่างๆว่างๆค่ะที่
คอนโดนะคะนักเรียนเดี๋ยวนะคะคู๋ต้องทำครู
ใหญ่ๆก่อน
[เพลง]
กูใหญ่มันขึ้นล่ะช้างคู่ใหญ่คู่หูสุดตัว
ใหญ่ให้ก็เพราะว่าเวลาเข้าไปใน YouTube
แล้วเหลือเล็กๆนะออก
โอเคค่ะตรงนี้นะคะชื่อที่คอนโดค่ะสีดำ
คอนโดที่ครูเอ๋อยู่ไหนตรงนี้จะมี
ระเบียง
ระเบียงก็ไว้ปลูกต้นไม้
ต้นไม้เก่าวัดข้างล่างตรงถนนนัดตรงนี้
เป็นป่าค่ะคุณต้อมอ๋อโอเคกูอีกอยู่ชั้น
อะไรคะปูเอ๋อยู่ชั้น 5 ค่ะ
ฉัน 5 นายแล้วชั้นล่างเนี่ยก็จะมีป่า
มีป่าเยอะๆมีต้นไม้เยอะๆใช่แล้วที่ป่า
เดี๋ยวคุณต้อมเขามีนกเยอะ
มีนกนะคะนะเนี่ยเยอะมากแล้ววันหนึ่งอ่ะก็
กดรางวัลนึงก็มีนกตัวนี้
แม่ตัวนี้ตัวที่หนึ่งเลย
น่ารักใจตัวเนี้ยตัวแรกเลยนะคะอ่ะเขาจะมา
ที่ระเบียงอันนี้เป็นต้นไม้ที่ตรงนี้เป็น
ต้นไม้ที่ระเบียงคู๋นะคะ
ตรงนี้เป็นเป็นป่า
ค่ะเอกขยายรูปออกมาให้เห็นเป็นป่าที่อยู่
ข้างล่าง
กูต้องรู้ไหมชื่ออะไรตัวเล็กๆไม่รู้อะเรา
ชื่อนกกินปลี
นกกินปลีชายตัวเล็ก
แต่ว่าชอบมาเวลากูเองมีน้ำเพราะว่าที่ตรง
นี้จะมีน้ำ
มีน้ำพุท
อาบน้ำ
เวลาฉีดมีน้ำเนี่ยน้ำนะฮะแล้วก็รดน้ำ
นกก็จะมาอาบน้ำขอ
ตัวนะชอบมาอาบน้ำก็ไม่อาบน้ำธรรมดานะคะ
ถ้าสมมติว่าครูเอ๋ไม่ยอมตื่นขี้เกียจนอน
นกตัวนี้ก็จะมาเกาะและ
เสียงกับเสียงแหลมแหลมอ่ะ
ประมาณว่า
อ๋อ
หนูมาปลุกใช่เป็นนกที่ชอบมาปลุกให้เรา
ตื่นนะคะ
ตรงเวลามากตัวนี้จะมาตอนประมาณ 7:00 น
7:00 นทุกวัน
พอ 7 โมงปั๊บถ้าวันเมื่อวันเสาร์วัน
อาทิตย์มันวันนี้วันอาทิตย์คู่เอกออนานๆ
มามัน
ตื่น
คือเสียงเขาไม่ใช่บอกว่าตื่นนะคะแต่ครู
เอ๋ฟังแล้วคิดตื่นเขาจะ
ถึงเขาอ่ะเสร็จแล้วพอเราตื่นเขาก็ไป
สามีคู๋นักเรียนตัวเองแต่งงานแล้วมีสามี
สามีครูเอ๋นะรักอันนี้มาก
รักนกกินปลีนะคะอ่ะตัวนี้ตัวที่หนึ่งนะ
ที่มาทุกวันแล้วก็มีอีกนี่นี่ตรงนี้
ระเบียงคุยปลุก
ระเบียงก็มีนกมาทำรางสกุลซ่อมอยู่ตรงนี้
ทำรังใช่แต่ว่าหลังให้หน่อยได้ไหมเห็นไหม
กูเอกกำลังว่านอยู่เห็นโอเคค่ะอ่ะนี่เป็น
รังจริงต้องสีน้ำตาลนะ
ลูกสีแดงออกอยู่ตรงนี้เลยค่ะคุณต้อง
วางเป็นเหมือนตะกร้าไม่ใช่ไหมกูเอ๋ใช่เรา
ก็มีนกตัวนี้กูต้องมีตัวนี้
นกกระจอกนกกระจอกนกหน้าจอนกกระจอกกับนก
กินปลีตัวเท่ากันไหมคะ on ยินตรี
สัตย์ขัดๆๆใกล้ๆกันแต่ gimp เล็กกว่า
โอ้โห
กระจอกใหญ่กว่าแล้วยังมีกระจิบอีกนะที่
เล็ก
แต่ไม่มีสิทธิ์จุ๊บ
ใช่หนังมากนี่ก็มีตัวนี้มาทำรังแล้วก็
แต่งงานแล้วก็มีลูกเยอะโอ๊ย
ว่าตอนนี้นะแม้จะอยู่ตรงนี้
[เพลง]
แล้วมีอีกคุณต้อมโอ้โหยังไม่จบนี่ก็มีนก
เขาใหญ่โอ้โหตอนนี้ร้องเก่งห้องสิ่งหู
เสียงเพราะจะจุ๊กกรู
ๆๆแล้วก็
ต้องเก่งมากเสียงเหมือนเขาก็ชอบมาที่นี่
แล้วก็ลงมาตรงนี้คุณต้อมแล้วก็หาอะไรกิน
ก็ไม่ทราบ
เอกก็ถ่ายรูปเองให้คุณต้องตรงนี้ป่าเป็น
ป่า
เขาก็จะบินมาแล้วก็มีเจ้าตัวนี้ด้วย
นกเขาชวา
กูมีกี่ตัวนะก็ต้องมีนกเขาชวานกเขาใหญ่
เขาใหญ่มากมา 2 ตัวนะคะก็จะว่าเนี่ยมา 4
ขอตัว
มาที่สุดคือ 4 บางทีก็หนึ่งบางทีก็สองบาง
ทีก็ 3 บางทีก็ 4 นะคะเราก็เขาใหญ่ก็มา
บัญชีหนึ่งบัญชี 2 มาเป็นคู่
มา
นกกระจอกเนี่ยสองอ่าเป็นครอบครัวเลยพ่อ
แม่ลูกเยอะเลยค่ะ
เราก็
นกตัวนี้ธรรมดานะเขามา 1 ครั้งสุดท้ายนะ
เข้ามาสามโหเมื่อเขามา 3 กับเป๊าะการพอ
เข้ามามาปั๊บคุณสามีหุบเหวภูต้อมมาค่ะ
อ่ะสัตว์มาที่นี้ใช่ไหมคะสามีครูเอ๋ก็
สามีก็คิด
เฮ้ย
นกกินอะไร
กินอะไรกินอะไร
ผู้ชายก็ God  Shop นกในรู้สึกนกมาทุกวัน
ร้องเพลงนกร้องเพลงใช่ไหมรู้จุ๊กกรูข้อ
ให้ผมเขาไม่รู้
อ๋อสามีก็คิดโอ๊ตมีอาหารนพดีไหม
ตัวเอกก็มีกล้วยที่บ้านหนอเอาว่าจะซื้อ
กล้วยไว้ที่บ้านบ่อยๆให้สัตว์มีกินก็เลย
แบ่งกล้วยไปให้นกขอ
เอากล้วยมาวางที่ระเบียงตรงนี้ค่ะ
นกชอบกินกล้วยคู๋คูเอกคิด
ตัวเอกคลิป
คิดว่านกจะกินกล้วย
[เพลง]
ก็เอามีมีที่วางกับงานแล้วก็เอาไม่ใช่นะ
คะเอากล้วยวางต่อมิอะไร
วางที่นี่มีกล้วย
เอก Copy กล้วยมาละกัน
รักกูเอกกะเอากล้วยน่ะค่ะ
มาเอาก็ใหญ่เสียว
เอามาวางวางเอาไว้หมุนก่อน
วางไว้ที่ระเบียง
เอากล้วยวางใครนกกินก็เลยมีที่มาว่าไม่มี
สัตว์เลี้ยงแต่เลี้ยงสระ
เข้าใจแล้วไม่งงนะไม่งง
งงหายไปแล้วเนาะ
ไม่ได้เลี้ยงเอาไว้ในบ้านหน้าอ้าเป็นนก
จากป่าตรงเนี้ยป่าแล้วนกก็มาก็จะรวยไปให้
ก็คิดว่าจะให้กูเอกคิดจะให้นกตัวนี้กินนก
นกเขาใหญ่นกเขาชวาเขาชวานกเขาใหญ่
นกกระจอกค่ะ
นกกินปลีน่ะให้เขาของกริชกูรวย
โง่ก็เห็นทุกวันนะน้อ
[เพลง]
ก็จะนกตัวนี้หนี
นกเขาใหญ่ก็กูเอกก็หายรูปไม่ๆเขาก็ไม่นี่
เขาก็มองหน้า
ฉลาดน่ะเขาไม่รู้ก็เขาคิดว่าครูเอ๋อ่ะใจ
ดีได้เขาไม่หนีเขารู้เองไม่ตีใช่ไหมคะ
โอ๊ยตัวนี้ยิ่งน่ารักเดินเดินครูเอกก็มอง
อย่างเงี้ย
อ่ะอ๋อคนแล้วก็เดินไม่บินหนีแต่ถ้าอาจจะ
เบื่อเอกก็โอเคไป
น่ารักมากตัวเองนะโอเค
มีกล้วยนี้รวย
นะเขากินกล้วยใช่ไหมคะคุกครูเอกคิดเขาจะ
กินกล้วยคู่เอกก็เปิดกล้วยเอาไว้แล้วมัน
มีนกมากินขอให้น้องเมะ
ไม่ใช่นกเขาอ่ะเป็นนกอ่ะอ้าวนี่ๆกดต้อง
เห็นไหมล่ะกูหูอะและอยู่ตรงนี้ค่ะหลังคุย
ไว้ตรงนี้นะเป็นนกตัวนี้ค่ะ
อ่ะหัวหน้าเนี่ย
เป็นนกปรอดหน้านวล
สวย
อันนี้ไม่ใช่รู้ของกูเองนะคะกูเอาจ้าแต่
ว่ากูเองไม่สามารถถ่ายเขาใครใกล้ๆได้มา
กินทุกวันนะ 5 เดือนแล้วอ่ะแต่พอถ่ายรูป
หนี
[เพลง]
แล้วก็ตัวนี้อันนี้นกปรอดสวนแบบนี้เลย
พี่นกปรอดสวนนกปรอดหน้านวลมากินก็โอเคนะ
สวยก็หนีจะโอเคไม่เป็นไรอันล่าสุดคือเจ้า
ตัวนี้ครูต้อม
คือ
นกอะไรคะนกกางเขนอ๋อ
[เพลง]
สวยสวยๆสีขาวสีดำ
อันนี้นะตอนนี้กลัวอยู่ตรงนี้นะคะแล้วก็
นกมา 3 ตัว
วันนี้มาตัวเดียวอ่ะแต่บางวันมา 3 ตัวพ่อ
แม่ลูก
คุณต้องเชื่อไหมครูเอ๋นะคิดจะเอากล้วยน่ะ
ให้นกนกเขาชวานกเขาใหญ่อ่ะนกกระจอกนกกิน
ปลีให้กินกล้วยนกทั้งหมดตรงเนี้ยตอนเนี้ย
หายไปหมดเลยค่ะอ้าวทำไมอ่ะคะ
ออกตอนที่นกปรอดมาอยู่แต่
นกกางเขนเนี่ยอา
มา
นกที่กรูเอกชอบหายไปหมดเลยโห
ตอนนี้มัน
นกกางเขนดุเนาะใช่ใช่ไล่นกตัวอื่นไปหมด
เลย
กูเอง
ไอ้กล้วยใช่ให้กล้วยไม่ให้กล้วยให้กล้วย
ไม่ให้กล้วยก็คิดเป็นคนชอบผมจะให้ไหม
ค่อยค่ะ
เอกก็คิดเองให้หนูไม่ให้ดีเพราะว่าถ้ามี
กล้วยมีนกกางเขนแต่ไม่มีนกเขาชวาไม่มีนก
เขาใหญ่ไม่มีนกกันจอบไม่มีนกเอ่อกินตรีมา
มีแต่เข้ากางเขน
อยู่แล้วแล้วมันนิสัยไม่ดีด้วยนะคุณต้อง
ยังไงคะ
เวลาเวลากล้วย
คือนกตัวเนี้ยค่ะค่ะต้องตัวเนี๊ยเนาะตลอด
เนี่ยอ่ากล้วยน่ะกูเอาวางไว้วันนี้น้อง
ตลอดก็มากินกินๆไม่หมดพรุ่งนี้มาก็อตกิน
โอเคโอเคไม่เป็นไรต้องรู้ไหมนกต่างเขียน
ทำยังไง
คะนกกางเขนมาวันนี้อ้อกล้วย fuel วางถ้วย
ใหม่ๆนกการเขียนกินจริงๆพอพรุ่งนี้มา
กล้วยออกรวยเมื่อวานมึงจะเปลี่ยนสี
เขียน
ไม่เอาหรอไม่ชอบไม่ชอบเอากล้วยไหมวะโนวา
มีเสียงเอกอะไรเพราะเอากล้วยใหม่ไปเงียบ
ร้านเขาก็จะกินกล้วยใหม่ๆรวยของเมื่อวาน
ไม่กินกินโอ๊ย
ตลาด
ฉลาดมันเสียมากตลาดมากเอกก็คิดโน้น
อายนกกางเข็นมาเฟียมากโอน K เองไม่ให้
กล้วยดีกว่าคิดนะถ้ากล้วยเสร็จนิ้วหมดไม่
ให้แล้ว
2 วันที่แล้วครูต้อมอ่ะ 2 วันที่แล้วครู
เอกก็ปิดประตูปิดหน้าต่างหมดอ่ะแล้วก็พอ
ตื่นปั๊มกูเองก็ไปนอนที่โซฟา
โซมันจะมีโซฟายาวๆใกล้ๆกับตรงนี้กูแอบ
ถ่ายจากในห้องมีกระจก
กระจกแบบนี้ค่ะอันนี้เป็นกระจกนะแต่ถ้าไป
อยู่ที่โซฟาแล้วเราก็ถ่ายรูปเขาแต่วัน
นั้นน่ะ oem  2 วันที่แล้วตัวเองปิดหมด
เลยปิดปิดๆๆ
นกกางเขนมาแล้วก็กล้วยนะไม่ใช่กล้วยใหม่
นกกางเขน
ร้องเพลงไม่ได้ยิน
โทรศัพท์แล้วก็เล่น
เล่นโทรศัพท์กูเองไม่สนใจไม่ได้ยินค่ะไม่
ได้ยินกล้วยหมดจะหมด 100 เปอร์เซ็นต์ไม่
มีเลยนะนกกางเขนร้องก็ไม่ได้ยิน
ติดติดทั้งหมดปิดหน้าต่างปิดประตู
เสร็จแล้วเจ้านกกางเขนทำอะไรรู้ไหมกูต้อง
ทำอะไรคะมันบินชน
หรอบินชนกระจกเลยเหรอคะตัวเอนนอนถ้าไม่
ใช่มั้ยที่โซฟามันก็ชนตัวเอกอะไรออกไปบ่อ
ก็มีนกกางเขนนะ 3 ตัว
ตรงนี้ 2 ตัวแล้วมี 1 ตัวเนี่ยคนที่นี่
แล้วก็บินกลับไปตรงนี้อ๋อ
ไอ้ตัวนี้ว่า
ชนแล้วก็ทนอีกแล้ว
ทำไม
ก็ลุกขึ้นมา
โอ๊ย
นกกางเขนไหมแค่นั้นนกกางเขนก็มองได้
ก็มองหน้าใช่ไหมคะแล้วก็ก้มลงไปที่ที่นี่
[เพลง]
น่า
รักอยู่มาเฟีย
ตัวเองอะไรเนี่ย
ก็เดินไปหยิบจะรวยมาแล้วก็เอาออกไปวาง
หน้าเพราะไอ้ออกไปเขาก็บินบินหนีไว้นะก็
อัลกรุดวางเขาก็มากินมากันห้องลูกมากิน
กินใหญ่เลยนะ
เสร็จแล้วเอกก็ไปทำอาหาร
ไม่สนใจ
สัมภัคซักพักนึงได้ยินเสียงร้อง
เสียงอะไร
เพราะจังเลยนี่ใครร้องคู๋
เสียงใครร้องเนี่ยเสียงเพราะจังเลยครูเอก
ก็สงสัยก็เดินออกมาดูเจ้ากางเขนหน้ากู
ต้องรู้
เขาเกาะแล้วเขาก็ร้องเสียงดัง
ยังพร้อมแบบ Who
ทำไมเสียบเพราะจังกิน
ก็ค่อยมาประมาณ 5 เดือนเนี่ยห้าเดือน
นะคะ 5 เดือน
ไม่เคยร้องเสียงเพราะๆให้ฟังขอบคุณแล้ว
กินอิ่มแล้วก็ร้องเสียว
มี
กูเอกกะวิ่งเข้ามาที่ห้องแล้วก็บอกสามี
สามีกำลังนอนใช่มั้ยก็จะมีก็ตื่นสามีบอก
นกตัวไหนร้องเพราะมาก
ไอ้แสบคน
เอเลี่ยนตัวนี้ว่าไอ้แสบไอ้แสบหมายถึงไม่
เรียบร้อยอ๋อ
มันตีนกตัวอื่นแล้วก็เอามานะเป็นนกมาเฟีย
เข้ามาห้ามกูเอ๋เรียกไอ้แสบ
ไอ้แสบคือทำให้นกนกก็ได้นะนกเขาใหญ่นกเขา
ชวานกยูงเข้าจอกนกกระจอกหนีไปหมดน่ะก็เลย
เรียกไอ้แสบไอ้แสบร้อง
อะมีก็โอ๊ยปอกกล้วยให้ตอนนี้ไม่มีรักไอ้
แสบขักหนูต้อมตอนนี้
ใจฮือเสียงเคาะๆเพียงพอที่คอนโดกูต้องมา
มีนกกางเขนอยู่หลายตัวสองตัว 4 ตัวแล้ว
เขาชอบไปว่ายน้ำที่สระว่ายน้ำเน่าหรอถ้า
มีให้น้ำเล่น 2 ตัวว่าย
ว่ายน้ำ
สะอาด
อาจเห็นว่ายน้ำบ่อยมาก
นิสัยไม่ดีอย่างเดียวชอบตีนกตัวอื่นไม่
ให้มานั่นแหละก็เลยแล้วไอ้แซ่บแต่เสียง
ร้องเพราะมากนะเสียงก็เพราะนะคะไม่ค่ะตอน
นี้ก็เลยโอเค
ยกระเบียงให้
ก็ต้องมีกล้วยมาให้นางเหมือนเดิมนะหา
เอ๋อะคิดถึงอันนี้คุณต้อมคิดถึงคิดถึง
น้องเขาใหญ่คิดถึง
เดี๋ยวก็มาคุยนกกินปลีมาไม่ได้การเขียนตี
การเขียนเป็นเมาเสีย
แล้วสิทธิ์กล้วยนะกูต้องคู๋เพิ่งรู้ว่า
ผีเสื้อกินด้วยหรอใช่เนี่ยผีเสื้อมากิน
วันก่อน
มันเป็นน้องน้ำอยากเป็นน้ำแล้วอ่ะนกกิน
กินในน้ำผีเสื้อมากินต่อโอ้ยที่ระเบียงกู
เอกเป็นซาฟารีเวิลด์ว่างเลยอ่ะ
แล้วพูดต้องเราคะเลี้ยงสัตว์อะไร
ก็ยังเอ๋นะอันนี้ไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่สัตว์เลี้ยง
ที่บ้านไม่ได้ซื้อมาไม่ได้เลี้ยงจริงๆเขา
บินมาก็เลยให้ไม่นะคะกูต้องเลี้ยงแมวน่า
จะโกรธหรือเปล่าไม่รู้เข้าไปหรอกไหมหรอก
กูต้องชอบเลี้ยงแมวจร
เดี๋ยวค่อยวาดให้เนาะแมวจรเหรอคะแมวจรค่ะ
แมวจรเป็นยังไงอ่ะรู้จักกันจอน
ชายแมวจรก็คือ
ย่อมาจากแมวจรจัดค่ะอ๋อโอเคว่าแมว
[เพลง]
สีดำดีกว่านะมันจะเป็นแมวที่เดินเดินๆ
อยู่ข้างนอกบ้านไม่ได้อยู่ในบ้านนะคะ
ได้มันก็จะเดินๆอยู่นอกบ้านเลยเขาก็จะไม
ให้มันเข้าบ้านเพราะว่ามันแบบตัวสุขกับมี
สปอร์อ๋อคือไม่ใช่แมวของก็ต้อมไม่ใช่แมว
ของเราเป็นงานที่ที่ถนนหรือเปล่าคะอันนี้
ถนนตายค่ะแล้วก็แมวนี่อยู่ที่นี่อยู่ที่
ตรงนี้เราเรียกอ่ะทางเดินเท้าหรือ 1 บาท
นะคะใช่ค่ะเป็นมันแมวไม่มีเจ้าของไม่มี
เจ้าของ
ต้องเดินไปแล้วเห็น
มันชอบมาเดินที่นั่งบ้านอ้ามาก่อนนะคะ
เมื่อก่อนกูต้องอยู่เป็นบ้านน่ะเล็กๆสอง
คนอยู่บ้านที่นี่ตาค้างถ้าอยู่ใกล้ๆบ้าน
คุณแม่ตรงนี้ก็มีแมวก็เพื่อมาที่นี่ๆมา
ค่ะแล้วมันก็จะมานอนด้วยนะเอ๋มานอนอยู่
หน้าบ้านค่ะ
เวลาเราขับรถกลับมาบ้านใช่ไหมคะมันก็นอน
อยู่หน้าประตูเราก็แบบไอ้ๆแม้ว่าเราจะขับ
รถเข้าไปในบ้านเราเข้าไม่ได้แล้วเข้าไปนะ
คะ
มันก็เอาตัวมา
อะตอมจะเข้าบ้านได้ยังไงอ่ะก็ต้องเอา
อาหารมาล่อมันพุ่งเอ๋มีรถอยู่ที่นี่
จะเข้าบ้าน
เอาไม่ได้
แล้วก็ไม่จัดศูนย์จักเขาจะกลับแล้วนะไม่
กัดไม่ตัดข้างมันชอบคนชอบอยู่กับคนป่ะเมล
ๆหนูเนี่ยนัวเนียอ๋อต้องก็ต้องเอาอาหาร
ให้เขา High ค่ะแล้วก็มาหลายตัวที่ 1 ตัว
ที่ 2
ที่ 3
ถูกต้องก็เลยซื้ออาหารเด็กเค้าไว้เป็นถุง
ใหญ่ๆค่ะเราก็ใส่ถ้วยเอาไว้ให้เขากินตอน
เมื่อเช้าออกไปทำงานก็เทอาหารเม็ดวางแวะ
เค้ากินไหมอิ่มหมดเกลี้ยงเลยจาก 1 ตัว
เป็น 2 ตัวเป็น 3 ตัวเป็น 4 ตัวเป็นกี่
ตัวค่ะแม่แค่ 3 ค่ะ 3 นะคะๆแต่มีอยู่ตัว
นึงอ่ะกูต้องอ่ะชอบมากเมื่อไรเอาเข้ามา
เลี้ยงในบ้านค่ะเรียบร้อยเรียบร้อยเป็น
แมวสีดำมึงโตใหญ่ตัวใหญ่แล้วค่ะเลี้ยง
ตั้งแต่ตัวเล็กๆจนเป็นตัวใหญ่แล้วตอนนี้
คุณอาของครูต้อมละเอาแมวตัวนี้เอาไป
เลี้ยงที่บ้านเลยเพราะว่ากูต้องอยู่คอนโด
แล้วได้ค่ะแล้วมันก็อ้วนน่ารักมากเลี้ยง
มาตั้ง
แต่ปีแล้วมั้งโหก็อายุประมาณ 8 นี่แมว 1
แมว 1 ปีเท่ากับคนอายุเท่าไหร่ 7 น้องหมา
เจ็บอะเหมือนกันมั้งน่าจะเหมือนกันมั้ง
ถ้า 8 ปี 8 ปีแล้วก็คูณ 7  8  58  68  7
เท่าไหร่
อายุพอๆกับเราแล้วนะเราแล้ว
เออกูก็คุณต้องเลี้ยงแมวจอดอะไรนะแมวจร
ถอดอาจารย์จัดไปค่ะไม่
เราเรียกว่าไม่ได้เป็นสัตว์เลี้ยงของเรา
แต่เรามีอาหารให้เขากิน
ทรายต้อมแล้วเพื่อนบ้านโอเคไหมเล่นบ้าน
โอเคเพื่อนบ้านใจดี
เพราะว่าถ้าบัญชีเรามีเพื่อนบ้าน
เพื่อนบ้านใกล้ๆแล้วเรามีอาหารให้แมวแล้ว
แมวมาเยอะๆแมวกินอิ่มแล้ว
เพื่อนบ้างบางคนไม่ชอบก็จะโกรธ
ใช่หรือว่าบัญชีแม่ก็กินเสร็จแมวก็ขอบคุณ
เราแต่ไป
ที่ตรงเนี้ยยายเหม็นใช่ไปขี้ที่นี่
อ่ะเพื่อนบ้านก็จะโกรธเหมือนกันนะคะมี
ปัญหานี้ไหมคะว่าแมวไม่มีค่ะเอาว่าแมวมัน
กินเสร็จแล้วมันก็ปีนขึ้นไปบนหลังคาคู๋
หลังกินขึ้นหลังคาจุ๊บๆไปถ่ายไปเลยอ๋อไอ้
นิสัยดี
มึงก็ไปขี้บนหลังคาฮะ
พี่เอ๋เพราะฉะนั้นนะเวลาที่ฝนตกอ่ะค่ะ
หรืออย่าให้น้ำฝนไหลจากหลังคาลงมาใส่เรา
นะมันจะเหม็นขี้แมวอ้าวเจ้านี่นิสัยไม่ดี
ละกินที่บ้านขี้บนหลังคาอันนี้น่างเอาไว้
เนี่ยก็ถือเรียกแมวจรจัดที่ครูเอ๋ถาม
เนี่ยแต่ถ้าเอานะเพื่อนบ้านโอเคไหมเขาขี้
ที่หลังคาบ้านต้อมหรือขี้หลังคาบ้านคน
อื่น
ป้อมคิดว่าไปทุกบ้านนะคะไปทุกบ้านฮ่าๆๆ
บ้านแล้วนี่ซะหน่อยก็เลยไม่เป็นไรกูเอก
เคยอยู่อพาร์ทเม้นท์แล้วมีระเบียงแล้ว
ห้องข้างๆผมต้องเข้าใจดีมากเขาให้อาหาร
แมวแมวจรจัดแล้วเขาให้นะเยอะจากแนว 1 ตัว
เป็น 2 ตัว 3 ตัวสี่ตัวห้าตัวหกตัวเจ็ด
ตัวแปดตัว 9 ทั้งตัวยกมือได้เราห้องเขา
ติดกับห้องเอ๋แล้วแมวมันก็รวมกันแล้วก็มา
กินยิ้มมันมาขี้ที่ห้องเอ๋ค่ะ
โอ้ยวันนี้ไม่ดีเลยตื่นเช้าว่ะขี้แมวอ้า
แรกๆกูเอกก็ล้างแปดล้านทุกวันไม่ได้อ่ะ
อยู่เรื่อยๆไม่เหนื่อยมากหรอกก๊อกๆให้
อาหารแมวใช่ไหมเก็บขี้แมวด้วย
อ๋อเก็บขี้แมวด้วยเขาก็ข้ามมาแล้วเขาก็
เก็บให้มันแบบนี้ค่ะต้องระวังนะคะใช่มา
ให้ดูพูดเองเล่าหมดเวลาแล้วนะเนี่ยอ่ะบอก
ได้แป๊บนึงนิดนึงนิดนึงนิดนึงนิดนึง
อันนี้นะคะเป็นระเบียงแบบนี้
เป็นระเบียงแบบนี้อะของเอ๋อยู่ตรงนี้
ระเบียงต่อกันห้องข้างๆเดินมาห้องเอ๋ได้
อ๋อเดินมาได้เขาก็เลยไปเอาก็เลยเดินมา
ด้วยแล้วเดินมาได้เขาเดินมาได้เพราะเก็บ
เอาออกไปโอ๋
ก็เลี้ยงนกเนี่ยนกก็ขี้เหมือนกันกูต้อง
รู้ขี้ฤทธิ์เดียวไม่เป็นไรอ่ะหน้าร้านทุก
วันนึกๆอะขี้นกอ่ะที่คอนโดกูต้องทำหลังคา
รถเลยนะนกพิราบ
นกพิราบด้วยนกกระจอกด้วยหน้านะนกเขาก็มี
แร่ของกูเองมีแต่ไอ้นกนี่แหละนมรบตัว
เนี้ยแล้วทำให้คนไม่ค่อยชอบไปจอดรถใต้ต้น
ไม้อ่าว่านกอยู่เยอะมาก
อ๋อถ้านกอยู่เยอะนกพิราบว่าจะขี้เยอะนะคะ
ต้องระวังไวรัสนะคะจริงๆระวังไวรัสไหมคะ
ใช่ๆหมดเวลาแล้ววันนี้หมดเวลาแล้วนะคะ
สำหรับวันนี้ก็นักเรียนคงไม่งงนะอ่ะเรา
สองคนเนี่ยไม่มีสัตว์เลี้ยงแต่ว่าเลี้ยง
สัตว์แต่ก็กลัวนิดหน่อยว่าเพื่อนบ้านจาก
โกรธไหม
8 โชคดีนกที่การเลี้ยงเนี่ยไม่ใช่ขี้นะ
คะมินิดหน่อยนิดเดียวนะคะแล้วนักเนี่ยนะ
คะมีให้อาหารสัตว์เขาเรียกว่าอะไรนะสัตว์
ที่ไม่ใช่สัตว์เลี้ยงไหมคะ
ของเราเนาะถ้ากูทำให้อาหารแมวเก๋น่ะให้
อาหารนกนะค่ะ
หมดเวลาแล้วน้องนั้นเอาไป
ทานั้นเราไปก่อนนะโอเคนะโอเคไปให้อาหารนก
ค่ะอาสวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋สวัสดีคะนักเรียนไม่
บายไงอ่ะ